vamos a ver si podemos encontrar una
fórmula o una expresión que nos quite de
problemas siempre que tengamos una serie
geométrica que por cierto este era mi
simbolito de serie y va a tomar una
asociación geométrica entonces quiero la
suma desde n igual a 1 hasta k de a por
ere a la enee menos uno y bueno para
hacer esto mucho más sencillo lo voy a
denotar colar ese subíndice que está
subiendo es acá estoy refiriendo a la
serie de los primeros términos de esta
sucesión climática que es precisamente
quien es a pues estos a por r más apple
no esperas verdad no es a poner esa
poder del acero cuando en la malla uno
me queda apoyar de lancero más a poner
cada uno cuando n vale 2 cuando el cne
vale 3 me queda apoyar al cuadrado masas
y así hasta llegar aa por ere a la k
menos 2 y después el último término me
quedarían más a por r al menos 1 muy
bien y yo lo que quiero encontrar es una
expresión muy sencilla que dependa de
camps para poder calcular esta serie así
que para que esto lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar ésta
expresión por ere es decir no voy a
tomar r a veces está ese subíndice cam y
justo ahorita vas a entender bien porque
no estoy tomando es re subiéndose acá
así que primero vamos a calcularlo a por
el acero por r pues esto es por el a1 y
lo voy a poner aquí abajo de a por
herrera 1 muy bien y después me tomo a
por herrera 1 por r pues me va a quedar
a por r al cuadrado muy bien y después
apoyo al cuadrado por r me va a quedar a
poner al cubo a poner al cubo y bueno
dejemos ponerle aquí los signos para que
entiendas que lo que está pasando
entonces aquí más más y vayamos todo en
orden más más más más todos estos y
después me quedaría ya llegando al final
aporrea la cara menos 2 x r no va a
quedar a por r a la cama menos 1 le
estoy sumando 1 la potencia y por último
quedaría a por r alak a menos uno por r
pues esto lo quedarían a por r al arca
muy bien ahora porque estoy haciendo
esto pero antes quiero que te des cuenta
que lo único que pasó fue que la
aumentamos 1 a cada una de las potencias
de r
lo que quiero realmente es resolver esto
para ese subíndice camps y parecer esto
lo que me voy a tomar es la diferencia
de estas dos como esto es igual a esto y
lo de verde son exactamente iguales por
lo tanto si yo me tomo la diferencia de
estos dos me voy a tomar la diferencia
de dos cosas iguales entonces lo puedo
hacer y para esto lo que voy a hacer es
pasar toda la expresión de abajo con
signo negativo es decir voy a distribuir
el signo menos por todos estos de aquí
me va a quedar aquí un menos aquí en
lugar de más le quedaría menos aquí me
quedaría menos aquí menos aquí menos
aquí menos x menos lo único que estoy
haciendo es multiplicando por menos uno
toda la igualdad de abajo y ahora sí si
me tomo la resta o la diferencia de
estos dos si me va a quedar bueno me va
a quedar este sub entre khan
- r veces ese subíndice acá esto es
igual a quien ahora date cuenta de que
esto va a estar sorprendente en primer
lugar esté aquí baja a por r a la cero
es lo mismo que a por uno porque
recuerda que todo el número elevado a la
cero es uno y ya por uno pues es lo
mismo que a entonces este de aquí es lo
mismo que a y
elimina con nadie y después todos estos
se cancelan esta se cancela este se
cancela eso se cancelan todos estos todo
esto se cancelan y al final solamente me
queda un menos a por el real acá todo
esto se fue y si estoy sencillamente me
quedo a menos a por era la cama está de
lujo porque entonces ya puedo resolver
esta ecuación para ese subíndice acá
vamos a despejar a este subíndice acá
entonces del lado izquierdo es la
factory sólo queda ese subíndice acá que
multiplicada 1 - r
esto es igual mientras que del otro lado
voy a actualizar a una y me queda aquí
multiplica a 1 - r elevado a la cama y
bueno ahora dividiendo todo entre 1 - r
todo entre 1 - r que me va a quedar que
ese subíndice k es igual a a que
multiplica a 1 - era la cam todo esto
entre 1 - r esta es la expresión que yo
quería encontrar súper padre para poder
hallar las series geométricas de los
primeros términos así que veamos un
ejemplo no voy a tomar
serie desde n igual a 1 la suma desde n
igual a 1 hasta 50 hasta 50 de la
siguiente sucesión geométrica 5 que
multiplica a un tercio elevado a la n 1
y bueno primero vamos a identificar cada
uno de los elementos de esta expresión
que tenemos aquí acá vale 50 hasta este
valor vamos a llegar a vale 5 y la razón
común vale un tercio y está genial
porque entonces ya podemos sustituir
esta fórmula y encontrar de una manera
muy rápida y muy sencilla
cuál es la suma de los primeros 50
términos de esta sucesión geométrica y
cómo lo podemos hacer pues vamos a
sustituir es decir esto me va a quedar
igual a amd es decir 5 que multiplica a
uno menos la razón elevado a la cama
1 - un tercio elevado a la potencia 50 y
a todo esto hay que dividirlo entre 1 -
la razón entre uno menos un tercio y
bueno aquí podemos usar la calculadora
meter todo esto en la calculadora y
encontrar un valor y eso va a ser mucho
más sencillo a tomarme la suma de los
primeros encuentra términos de esta
sucesión imagínate
sería bastante cansado y serían más
cansados
en lugar de 50 500 términos entonces
aquí solamente sustituimos de 500
encontramos rápidamente a cuánto
equivale esta serie en lugar de sumar 1
por 1 en fin lo que quería que te das
cuenta es que esta fórmula es súper
padre